if you doubled in size your weight would
be eight times greater that's the
trouble with growing tall
gravity's pool is keeping us all down
but there are a few earthly Giants that
have fought gravity and won the key to
growing tall is how you use your energy
that's why the tallest trees outrank any
animal on earth because trees spend all
their energy on one thing growing taller
than their fellow neighbors and there
are two trees that are the best growers
of them all giant redwoods in mountain
ashes redwoods are renowned as the
tallest life-forms on earth but some
experts think that mountain ashes could
grow even taller if humans would stop
cutting them down in fact the tallest
mountain ash was just one meter shorter
than the tallest redwood unlike plants
animals spend energy on all sorts of
tasks like eating walking and staying
warm so they can't grow as tall but it
doesn't mean they're small either if you
measured this African elephant from
shoulder to ground it would actually be
taller than a giraffe but thanks to
their long strong necks giraffes are the
tallest animals alive and if we look at
animals throughout Earth's history
dinosaurs eclipsed them all these
towering Sauer pods were the biggest of
the bunch in fact the top ten list of
tallest animals in history all dinosaurs
but what if we looked at the longest
life-forms to
if you balance the longest saltwater
crocodile on its nose it would tie the
giraffe and if we ignore legs it gets
even better tip to tail the green
anaconda nearly doubles the height of
the tallest giraffe but these land
dwellers have nothing on animals of the
deep supported by water sea life can
practically ignore gravity which means
they can grow much larger take the blue
whale for example it's the most massive
animal of all time for example the
entire cast of Broadway's The Lion King
can fit on its tongue but it should be
careful not to get tangled up in the
tentacles of a lion's mane jellyfish
which makes the giant squid look small
by comparison now the biggest fish alive
is the whale shark and if we look into
the past things get even bigger so where
do humans fit into all this somewhere
near the top actually humans are bigger
than 87.6% of mammals on earth and the
average Dutchman is the tallest of them
all so there's no reason to ever feel
small again especially if you're from
the Netherlands
fun fact the longest life form of all
time isn't a plant or animal at all it's
a honey fungus and the biggest one goes
on for three point eight kilometers
under Neath a forest in Oregon